In this universe
Ronan the accuser, betrayed Thanos.
The mad titan's thirst for power
had met its match, If you keep the path,
you can find your way to the light.
Well, well, well.
If it isn't the super-nova
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
This will be my full marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 1 Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I talked about this in previous videos too,
but they're doing episodes one per day,
so my episode videos will post each morning,
usually around the same time.
careful for spoilers from episode one.
If you haven't seen it yet, we'll start
at the beginning. Work our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title.
What if Nebula joined the Nova Corps?
It's basically what if Nebula turned good
and became a version of Nova?
Much earlier in the timeline?
Then she became good in the MCU.
Like what if she got her redemption much, much earlier?
the Marvel logo.
Opening
titles are a little bit different for season two.
They're doing the shorter version
of the opening Marvel logo
that they did recently for Loki Season two episodes,
where it plays a very sped up version
of the traditional Marvel Studios logo TV shows
just in general tend to favor shorter intro titles.
There are a couple of exceptions to that,
but usually it's just like, Bam, Quick Flash,
the title went to the actual episode instead of doing
like a really long version of intro scenes.
if you go back to the original Marvel
Phase four episodes, most of the episodes
in all the series
played the full version of the Marvel Studios intro.
Eventually,
they started shortening that. Starting this year.
so expect all their future TV series to play like this
shorter version of the logo
customized for each different series,
like when we get to X-Men 97 episodes
because it'll be released under Marvel Studios.
So the intro will be just like a little bit different
or like the Echo episodes are going to be happening
at the beginning of January, right?
Or this like Echo is like the next big series
that I'll be doing episode videos for after this.
but don't worry
too much about what's going on with that,
because that live action stuff
doesn't have too much connection with what's happening.
On what if season two right now, all the comics
pages, flipping in the background during this opening
title are from the original What if comics
they usually change that to be for whatever
characters or show
the movie is about from their respective comics.
a couple of times, though, where they do like custom
intro titles, like for Guardians of the Galaxy three,
where it's just the Guardians characters
instead of all the different Marvel characters.
in just like what if Season one,
they transitioned the regular live action
Marvel Studio title to the animated version
because it is an animated series.
There've been a couple instances
where they blended live action with animated elements
like Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
They passed through an animated universe.
They just seem like one of the universes in
the multiverse is an animated universe.
That's kind of the way that this stuff is canon
to the live action MCU stuff through the multiverse.
Like these are just taking place in animated universes.
this also explains how X-Men 97 or X-Men
the animated series is canon to the larger MCU.
In the grand scheme of things, it's
just another universe that happens to be animated.
they're also going to blending live action
and animated elements during the Spider-Verse movies
like Spider-Man Across the Spider-Verse.
this is Donald Glover's Prowler character
from the events of Spider-Man Homecoming.
Just after the events of that movie, they'll continue
to do that during Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse.
Generally,
the episode is mostly meant to be a Blade Runner
riff on the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
and the Nova comics
with a bunch of other space based characters
like John Rogue from the Captain Marvel movies.
Jude Law came back to voice his character from that.
Corrigan Meek from the Thor movies are back.
Taika Waititi also came back to do his voice
for the most part in all the What If episodes.
All the movie actors came back to do their voices
in animation.
With a few exceptions.
really good example is that Glenn
Close is not doing the voice
for Nova Prime during this episode, Take my hand.
the opening scene is of Nebula finding.
Yondu was murdered body in an alleyway on Zander.
And even though Yondu is in the episode,
Michael Rooker came back to do
his voice
and is credited in the episode for the Yondu character.
He doesn't have any speaking lines
in the actual episode.
He speaks in other episodes, though, Like I said,
the whole vibe here, like the very noir crime
thriller Pouring Rain Here, is meant to be a reference
to the Blade Runner
movie like Tears in the Rain.
same thing with all of Nebula is constant.
VOICEOVER Just like Deckard's voice overs in the Blade
Runner movie, things are meant to pick up.
A little while after Zander had erected a planet wide
shield wall to keep out Ronan,
the accuser during the events of the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie.
And in this reality, Ronin successfully killed
Thanos when he tried to double
cross him in the first Guardians movie, Nebula explains
in this universe, when Ronan came to sanctuary,
he was able to kill Thanos.
Somehow, in the ensuing fight, kill Gamora
and the rest of the Black
Order two, except for her, like left her for dead.
are a couple references to the Black order
during this episode.
I think the idea is that
Ronan accuser was able to take the power stone
and kill all the others,
or they didn't find the power stone in the first place.
They don't really show you him using the power stone.
So I'm assuming that he probably didn't
find it in this episode.
there's also no mention of Star-Lord finding the power
stone in this episode or Star-Lord just in general.
during the aftermath, Nova Prime took pity on Nebula,
brought her into the Nova Corps,
this being soon after the events of this moment
in the first Guardians movie.
And even though Nova Prime and the Nova Corps
all kind of turned evil through the course
of the episode, over the course of five years,
it seems like they're saying, at least at first,
Nova Prime had good intentions
when she brought Nebula into the fold, so to speak.
Like she didn't start out being corrupt and evil.
so when she puts up the shield
wall over the entire planet that's meant to have been
during the final battle
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
but things went down differently
like Star-Lord isn't here.
Some of the other Guardians characters
like Rocket doesn't seem like he's here either.
then about five years go by with everybody
who was on planet, trapped on planet,
with nobody being able to get off planet
or get into the planet.
Like they're literally trapped
in an isolationist environment in there is explained
that it winds up making things worse.
Ultimately, though,
even though protects them from Ronan, it makes things
worse on the planet because it's sort of rotting
metaphorically at the core.
all the ravagers are still a thing.
Yondu seemed like he was still leading them before
he was killed or what was left to them on the planet.
When the shield wall went up.
I'm sure the larger group of Ravagers who were outside
on another part of space, elected another leader
like Starhawk, took over that part of the Ravagers
they're probably off doing their own thing
or some other part of the galaxy at the moment
then a bunch of the corrupt Nova Corps members
show up like Peter Serafinowicz, his character
from the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie.
He came back to do The Voice again.
during the episode, he's basically playing like a worse
version of his character from the first movie.
If you remember in the first movie,
he wound up sacrifice ing his life
to save everyone from Ronan.
they brush off Yondu his death, claiming
they don't need to investigate because Yondu was a
career criminal.
They also probably killed him
because they found out that he discovered their plans.
Nebula clocks him, noting that he's super sus.
He doesn't want to investigate Yondu, whose murder.
He was also close to Yondu, it sounds like, to
Is there a problem?
Corpsman? This is Dandora.
we got a problem.
She also winds up revealing later on
that she suspected them the entire time.
It was just kind of leading them along,
letting them think that
she didn't understand what was really going
on, to draw them out.
so the whole idea is that
Nebula is meant to be like three or four steps ahead
of all of the other characters in the novel core
when he calls her Blackwater trash, remember
the Blackwater were the so-called children of Thanos,
so to speak,
like the people that he adopted across the world
that he conquered like Gamora.
We saw most of them during the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies, Avengers, Infinity War, Avengers, Endgame
within the MCU.
They were Gamora, Nebula, Ebony,
Ma, Proxima, Midnight, Corvus Glaive and Col Obsidian.
Like I said, I think Ronin killed
pretty much all of them except for Nebula.
In this reality. Nebula goes back to her flying car.
That's also meant to be a reference
to Deckard's police car from the Blade
Runner movie and the constant rain all over the place.
then they play the custom.
What if intro scene with the shards
for many alternate realities
like facets of glass windows goes into other realities.
all the Watchers voiceover dialog
here is also from the season one intro.
Like a lot of these scenes and moments
in these background shards are from season one would
they've changed though about this is they've added
shards of glass from season two episodes too.
So it's kind of season one episodes mixed with season
two episodes because this is my episode one video.
This is like the first time addressing this.
I'll do like the full breakdown
for what's in all of these shards
for this episode,
but it'll be the exact same for every single episode.
So I won't repeat this for episode to episode three
and so on.
generally the intro progresses in the same fashion as
the season one intro, but it starts with Black Panther.
In his original suit
from the Captain America Civil War movie,
he got a new one during the first Black Panther movie.
Captain Marvel is also wearing her original suit
from the first movie
because it's just her from that Season one intro.
that's why you don't see her wearing her
brand new suit from the Marvel's movie
Iron Man is wearing his Mark 50 armor from Avengers
Infinity War, the first version of the Nano suit.
Thor is wearing a golden version of his armor
from the first Thor movie.
He also continued wearing that
through the first Avengers movie to Black Widow
changes between a couple of different versions.
Like it seems like they do her with the red hair
from the first Avengers movie in that suit,
then transitions to her blond here in her suit
from Avengers Infinity War, Lake Bell
also voices Black Widow in all of her
different episodes, like all the different universe
versions of that character,
She voiced the character during season
one and also Fun Real-Life Connection, too.
She was also in Black Panther, well, kind of forever
as this character here briefly.
this is the Steve Rogers, Captain America
in his Avengers Age of Ultron armor.
Then is the camera pans out,
they split to a bunch of alternate universes
just starting from the top left, going to right.
I can't tell whose eyeball this is.
Like, it's a little too zoomed in on his face.
This seems like the red Hydra book
that they used to control.
Winter Soldier, this is Captain Carter.
This is the Frost giant form of Loki,
who is from a reality where Odin never took him in.
He was just raised by Frost Giants.
This was like Thor in his armor from Thor,
The Dark World.
This version of Ultron
seems like he's the season one Ultron
who got all the Infinity stones and became
a living Infinity gantlet below him as Heimdall.
Then there's Chadwick Boseman, Star-Lord,
Black Panther from season one.
I can't tell who's right next to him.
Like I said, some of these scenes are from season
one down at the bottom,
starting at left, going to right there, Spider-Man
when Wu from the Shang Xi movie.
He's one of the new characters this season below him,
I think is a scene
from the Marvel 1602 episode Zombie Scarlet Witch.
Seems like she's from season one here.
This is a young version of Bill Foster Goliath.
He's in that 1980s Avengers episode
that's going to be episode two.
I can't tell who's next to him.
But then Gamora seems like she's from the Iron
Man Sarkar episode
this season, Supreme Strange is right next to her.
this just Captain America Shield from the first Captain
America movie still stuck in the ice.
Below them is Iron Man in the donut
from the events of Iron Man two.
I think this scene is also from his episode
in season one, when the camera zooms out
a little more,
the shards break change again, two different universes.
There's child Gamora from the events of Avengers
Infinity War, Winter Soldier right below her.
we get a new scene of a younger version of Red Guardian
next to them in his armor.
I don't know which episode he's in.
He also might be in the 1980s
Avengers episode or something totally different,
I think this is meant to be shown.
She is mother.
This is Topaz.
Next to her, the new character K Hori.
I can't tell who's above them with the blond hair
Next to them Seems like a version of Thunderbolt.
Ross This is another version of Loki from earlier
in the timeline.
Seems like the events of the first Avengers
movie down at the bottom
from left to right
is Marvel from the 1980s Avengers movie.
I think that Annette Bening
came back to voice her again.
Nick Fury This seems like a younger version of Shuri.
This is Ant-Man, probably also from that 1980s
Avengers episode, and it's the Hank Pym version of Amy.
And on that 1980s Avengers. them.
We get Nebula with Yondu, Stan from episode one,
which we're in the middle of right now
when she joins the Nova Corps.
this is hella in one of her episodes.
I believe she's in a couple
this season when the camera zooms out again,
there are a couple more characters
visible around the edges of the frame here.
Iron Man Up top.
This is Obadiah Stane over on the far right.
I think he's also from season one
then because this episode is the Nebula episode,
the camera zooms into her particular fragment
like it's traveling into Nebulas universe here.
and we get another montage as the intro continues
to zoom through a bunch of different realities.
one of the differences, though,
is that all the realities that it zooms through
during this part are from season two episodes.
some of these fragments are a little too blurry
and small to actually see,
but this one is the Hulk from the Marvel 1602 episode.
This is Black Panther, and it's actually King
to chuck a Black Panther during the 1980s
Avengers episode because that version back in the 1980s
winds up joining that Avengers team.
and it is the same actor who played the live action
version of the Young
King to Chaka in the first black Panther movie,
coming back to do the character again.
is meant to be Black Widow with red hair.
Next to her is Skinny Boy Steve Rogers as a version
of the Winter Soldier in Captain Carter's reality.
This scene, The Grandmaster,
I think, is from the Iron Man episode this season.
This Odin is also from the Hella Sheng
Shi ten Rings episode this season.
I'm not sure which episode this Winter Soldier is from.
It also might before that 1980s Avengers
episode, there's another version of Captain Marvel.
This seems like it's relatively close to present day,
and then the rest of this intro plays
the same from the season one intro with the Watchers
voice over being the exact same.
we get a little more narration from the Watcher
explaining the backstory.
This universe already kind of explained how things
went differently between Ronin Thanos in the Black
order, Basically, Nebula finds the schematics
for the shield wall that Yondu had obtained
and kept in as thin an arrow weapon, which she winds up
taking later in the episode as her own.
they bring back Jude Law's John Rod character
from the first Captain Marvel movie,
claiming that he was also on planet
when The Shield Wall went up and had been working
with Nova Prime and Ronin to bring the Shield down
and take over the planet.
Notice.
She also clocks Nova Prime when she says to use
any means necessary to solve the case.
That was what tipped her off.
That Nova Prime was probably in on this.
she goes to Howard, the Duke's underground casino
that he's been running.
Seth Green comes back to voice the character again.
He voices him in live action
Guardians of the Galaxy movies
to most of the characters in general
are from the Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
In the Thor movies, in the way they explained,
this is all these characters were on the planet
when that attack
was happening in the Shield Wall went up,
and they've been trapped on the planet ever since then.
so like Groot was on planet but Rocket was not.
Which is why Rocket isn't here with Groot.
also notice is still the original version of Groot,
not Groot, son, who is like the new version of Groot.
That's the way James Gunn explains.
And he's kind of like Groot, son, basically.
Who's the giga chad version of Groot?
Now they're calling the swole version of Groot.
Now the Alpha Groot.
so this way, this version is super skinny.
Like, he is not meant to be Alpha Groot.
He's the original version of Groot.
Meek is here from the Thor
movies, is tending bar and working as a chef.
Drax is at the slots.
Taika Waititi comes back to voice Coric,
who's the main bartender, in.
They basically discover
that Yondu had learned about the plot
to bring the shield down
when she breaks yarn, rock out of prison.
Like I said, Jude Law came back to voice his character.
It is also a reference to the prison break
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie.
Like all the prison uniforms
are the same color of yellow.
It's the same type of prison run by the Nova Corps.
the way they escape is also similar
to the way the Guardians
escaped in the first movie
by disabling the power briefly.
part of the idea here to, I think, explaining why John
Rogue is here is because he is Cree, just like Ronin.
The accuser is just that.
John Rogue is a pink skinned Cree,
which is why he doesn't look the same.
but they're part of the same army.
They were working together
during the first Captain Marvel movie.
so makes sense that he would be working with Ronin
to try and take over the planet secretly.
one of the only other real differences with Roan,
the accuser, is that he is part of the accuser corps,
which is like a special hardcore
sect of their military Nebula
basically uses John Rogue to help bring out Nova Prime
and confirm her theory that she was part of this.
And that's what she means when she says
she doesn't need him to understand what they're doing.
she only needs him to live up to his reputation
because she wants this double cross
that he pulls to actually go down
so that it will help bring out Nova Prime.
and basically the core here
is like the MCU version of the Nova Force,
which is a bit of a reference to the Nova comics,
the actual Nova character.
They are working on an actual Nova project, even though
they kind of turn Nebula into a version of Nova.
During this episode.
So we'll eventually get actual Nova from the Nova
comics in the MCU at some point when it calls Nebula
an Omega class being,
that's a reference to Omega class mutants
in the X-Men comics.
Like I'm not expecting a ton of X-Men stuff during
what if season two because they started working on it
before the actually got a lot of their Fantastic
Four X-Men stuff going in.
We have X-Men 97 coming
really soon after these episodes.
But in reality, Nebula is not a mutant.
And she's not meant to be an Omega level
mutant at that.
They're only about 14 Omega level mutants
right now in the comics.
The most powerful ones are like the most common ones
people think of are Franklin Richards,
Jean Gray, Phenix, Magneto, Iceman, Storm Legion.
Those are just some of the notable ones, though.
Interestingly enough, though, like Apocalypse,
for instance, not classified currently as an Omega
level mutant, because in order to be classified as one,
it has to be based on your core power.
In a lot of apocalypses,
power is taken from other people's powers
or from like celestials, for instance,
is where it gets all of its technology from.
we'll get really deep into the weeds on X-Men
lore, X-Men Easter Eggs during the X-Men 97 episodes.
Pretty soon.
Nebula successfully tricks them into believing
that they were able
to double cross their Nova Prime reveals her treachery.
Howard the duck then helps repair Nebula.
And part of the joke here,
I think it also took all of her winnings
from the slot machine in exchange for his help.
Like, okay, it will repair you,
but I'm going to take all this stuff.
When he jokes about pawning her for parts.
That's also a reference to something
that Thanos mentioned during Avengers Infinity War.
they have great her with Yondu Is Fin an arrow weapon,
which he continues to use after
the end of the episode, and they form a new version
of the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Basically, like this
is meant to be a new Guardians of the Galaxy team.
Nebula Taking everyone out with Yondu,
Spin is also a reference to the Guardians of the Galaxy
two movie, where Yondu basically did the same thing
to all the Ravagers
She reveals that she changed
the shield codes during her download,
causing them to close on Ronan's ship,
the Dark Aster, destroying it and killing Ronan.
meaning that after the end of the episode,
there's no more need for the shield.
Well, they just bring it down
permanently after this core, it basically
pulls a Hulk versus Loki thrashing him
like in the Avengers movie.
On John Rogue, the other
Nova core member in Nova Prime inadvertently
causes her own death when she tries to kill Nebula
while she's attempting to save her R.I.P..
during the outro, the Watcher ends
with a voiceover about Nebula's redemption,
which they kind of did in the MCU.
It just took way, way longer to happen in the MCU.
Finding her way to the light, quote unquote,
referencing her Nova core vow
she took earlier in the episode
when she joined the Nova Corps.
I think the idea here is that after
the end of this episode, she goes back to regular Nova
Corps duty, assuming that they dealt with all the other
corrupt members on the team during the end credits.
They play background scenes from across the episode.
They all look like really amazing wallpapers
do like those really cool scenes from each episode.
So I'm assuming the end credits for every single
episode will change just based on different scenes
from each particular episode that's basically
what they did during the season one episodes.
Like all of the end credits
scenes were unique to each episode.
there were bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if you spotted any that I didn't talk about
in the video, just write them below in the comments.
My Episode 2 video will post tomorrow morning.
It'll be the 1980s Avengers episodes.
Those should be pretty cool in each episode post
around the same time each morning through the finale.
Remember, there are nine episodes total.
This is what the schedule actually is.
There's also a bunch of other stuff
happening the next couple of days this weekend.
So I'll try to do videos for Zack Snyder's
Rebel Moon in Aquaman, two in the next couple of days,
so make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here for that
What If
Season 2 Episode 2 Video. I'll update the link
as soon as I post
that tomorrow and click here for all my
What if episodes
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!